[Music]
now I'm gonna kiss for that [ __ ] oh
why is the door laws why can't we just
have the [ __ ] door open
prisoners or not this systems do my
nuttin just screwing up any chance
getting anything done efficiently and I
think we like it we do go into
production and we are busy I mean
opening a locker like a chopping board
you know ladles because they're not
etched I mean all these guys gonna do
with a chopping board Laurens number six
where's your box it's the moment of
truth time to get the knives out yeah if
we're gonna make any money out of this
kitchen my brigade have to have the
tools to do the job offer you be careful
however dangerous they may be be look
are they next number
times like this I wish you guys were
just internet fraud knock young crimes
got an Internet fraud I can have the
whole thing open every day
no one's here to turn play around with
knives see anyone that's behaving as if
they want to use the knife for be
miscellaneous and a knife or anything in
this kitchen
I've got criminals not chefs one of them
Lawrence Gibbons has got a list of
convictions as long as my arm that
robbing banks and when I've got resting
arms in county prison under mom's mommy
come up and visit only price we start in
the house you said never time to get the
guy's 45 years of age he stuck in his
ways and I've seen him work bloody good
I mean he can graft but he has a temper
me a big-time
guys taste as well don't forget Noah's
tasting yeah for this business to work
all my brigade have got to become a team
but lions can't seem to work alongside
Ren a Smith
not me
seriously come to my charlie it's simple
you're not
did so jolly
[ __ ] about that nothing
sometimes when you work on a wind the
atmosphere changes and it's a very
subtle change it feels unsettled in
place of Planet erupt like sometimes
it's over the slightest
[Music]